hey show Robin the new Gary puppet we've
upgraded yeah I you know it's funny I
didn't know we were making a Baba Booey
puppet but they're [ __ ] scary this
was unbelievable show it to her
oh my goodness sure show her this jacket
is where look at that
that's his Darrin yeah well that'll be
the only thing that's inaccurate is the
weight oh yeah no offence of the teeth
toe but it smells better I'm a fan of
the old Doug puppet
hold it next hand open your mouth like
the puppet I put them right next to your
head smell what's the matter why can't
you put a make sure I got salt and
pepper gone I understand like being that
guy or do you prefer I have to be that
guy yeah I've on a desert island of hat
that's Steely Dan I like your impression
better I think I like it - yeah I like
when you talk even though he doesn't
sound like that I know Gary puppet I
understand you were over at the Brady
Bunch I was over the vivos house I had
to wait for Jon Hamm to go outside
because I wanted my own picture by the
couch yeah until the dog was and Alice
yeah I thought it was weird that like
you took a whole series of pictures with
Jon and then you needed your own set of
pictures Jon go outside I have to have
my own memories hey by the way if you
don't mind Gary puppet can you give me
your top ten desert island music list
again it's so fashionable see Steely Dan
sidelong of Asia on the run of course
Hall & Oates would have to be in there
but I cannot decide which album it would
be if it would be h2o not you but I've
got I'm calling sleepovers about you